all right republicans in new york are in
a battle to take control in some
respects for example the governor's
mansion uh and they just added a handful
of new republican house members too you
got republican lee zeldin and gop
assemblyman mike lawler are in very
tight races in fact lowell is now up on
a guy against democratic governor kathy
hoco and sean maloney who's considered a
rising star on the left those two races
are among a half dozen that are really
competitive this year what is it about
the republicans in new york are they
getting are they actually they're able
to kick off the respirator joining us
right now is the co-host of the number
one morning show in new york city uh the
star of bernie and sid in the morning
sid rosenberg is here and his new book
citizens united is now out tells his
story and also what's important to the
people of new york correct it is all
correct thank you i love the king of new
york i'm going to steal that right i
made that over the top of my head and i
do i do think it was a demand of your
appearance
first off new york ready to flip people
on the outside go what are you talking
about new york has never been so liberal
but you think zelda's got a real shot i
think he's got a shot is it ready to
flip that's still a tough call because
like you talk about the numbers are not
in our favor but two to one democrats
outnumber maybe even more but people are
sick and tired of the crime which is
skyrocketing every day 39 percent the uh
robberies are up 21 aggravated assaults
are up they're sick of it they're sick
of seeing the homeless all over the
streets the filth the taxes people are
fleeing in big numbers and guess what
both republicans and democrats want
safety and clean streets it's no longer
a partisan issue i think people are
waking up and i do think zeldan will
make this a very close race he can win
this it comes down to who debates better
if in fact kathy hulkel decides to
debate uh you know over the last few
days she's been on the cover of new york
post because she will not commit to
doing it she did it verbally but won't
commit to a date if she waits too late
with early voting done it'll work on her
on her uh behalf it's hard to see her
numbers growing now about sean maloney
really vulnerable here i think so i
actually spoke to mike lawler a couple
of days ago it's the same situation
brian what's happened now is that local
politics equal national politics so the
same things we're talking about on a
national level right the border crime
safety taxes that's exactly what we talk
about locally that gives mike waller a
shot in his county a very very big
county here in new york right now he's
beating maloney by two points in the
latest poll so what's kind of
interesting is we've been covering it on
fox and friends in the morning i don't
know if you have on port authority the
income about 70 80 people on these buses
from texas mayor adams at first was very
angry now i don't think he's i think
he's on his heels a bit he commented
yesterday on our situation the border we
are writing checks in new york city to
set up a illegal immigrant center which
is unbelievable here is uh mayor adams
talking on thursday about the illegal
immigration policy of the administration
try to make sense of this
anyone who states
that this administration
does not have
a handle on this crisis
they must have been sleeping under iraq
the republican party
they have created
a
blueprint
it's inhumane
for
the governor to send
immigrants
to
martha's vineyard without any
coordination
it's just creating
real a real crisis are they wearing mass
to stop from laughing come on what does
that mean i don't know look i cover eric
adams very closely here in new york and
uh he was the guy i liked when he was
brooklyn borough president something has
happened to him well d happened to him
democrat and at this point he's starting
to make bill de blasio look like i don't
know einstein he can't get a sentence
out he doesn't explain himself very well
the truth is is that going to martha's
vineyard or new york city if you're a a
migrant an illegal migrant not such a
horrible thing could be a heck of a lot
worse so i'm not sure the hurricanes is
complaining about it we'll say this
governor abbott and governor desantis
are two real american heroes those are
two great patriots in my book then what
this country is all about not eric adams
and of course you're talking about the
fact that he took some of the illegals
in uh in florida sent to martha's
vineyard and abbott sent him to the vice
president's house that's gorgeous here's
with the late-night hosts they have a
different view sid of what these two
governors did watch
the worst things about donald trump is
all his dummy minimes these
all these elastic pants governors who
are pulling their own little stunts too
excited stupid ron desantis is that guy
he went to high school with who
desperately wanted to be prom king but
he didn't have any charisma so instead
he just pulled the fire alarm and ruined
the dance for everybody
of course desantis wasn't sending these
folks to the vineyard to have a good
time he was human trafficking these
families as a political stunt
what's your take on this do they
understand that 8 000 illegals are
coming through a day that they're
complaining about 60 and he thinks it's
funny they understand they're not stupid
i mean jimmy kimmel should be moored
about his own show these days he's in
big trouble any calm alone impressions
lately jimmy kimmel and the other guy
also is a very very smart guy they know
it all they're doing is spouting out
regurgitating democrat policy like you
said texas gets 8 000 a day we get like
80 and we're like oh my god what are we
going to do they got to stop inhumane
we're giving these people dinners and
tickets and fancy hotel rooms i should
be treated that well right you are
treated that well i think you are a
royalty here in the city uh sid you'll
said the huge sports background so this
is not hard for you to stretch this how
important is aaron judges run for the
single season home run record he's about
to he's on the cusp of beating marist
he's he's uh in the high 50s already
what's your take on what this means and
sports put in perspective it's a huge
deal maris hits 61 judge has the brewers
the next couple of days uh he's going to
break that record if not in milwaukee
then sometime next week and i think he's
got pittsburgh after that he does the
pirates exactly so bad ball clubs uh
he's a good guy there are no steroid
controversies or any of those rumors
surrounding aaron judge neither was
roger morris of course but ever since
marist brother was bonds or sosa mcguire
maguires you know brian every a-rod
every big homerun hitter had that
steroid thing around them not aaron
judge good guy new yorker loves kids
charitable hits home runs like we go to
work that's true uh and by the way by
about 30 home runs over the number two
which is unbelievable he had a shot at
the triple crown sid you wrote your book
you talk about sports you have all these
anecdotes why are you a giant fan what
do the jets do to you oh don't bring
this up this is very painful for me
brian
when i was a little kid i actually won a
contest at a s department store in new
york city to be the mascot of the week
for the jets i was going to allow me to
sit on a bench with joe namath and
emerson
and the jets decided because they were
one and five they're head coach charlie
winner that little sydney ferris
rosenberg from brooklyn would be a
distraction and instead they called my
father and sent me a signed football on
that day 47 years ago i became the
biggest new york giant fan ever
and you told joe namath that too right
three days ago he loves that story he's
been number one in new york with bernie
uh fantastic success in abc
congratulations on your book it's great
story i love you thank you and sid goes
up and down but he always gets up and
he's continues to fight thank you very
much rosenberg i want i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now